A FEW MINUTES, AS THEY PREPARED
TALK ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
OTHER BIG ISSUES.
WE START OFF WITH CHIEF
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE ON WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A PLANNED TERROR ATTACK IN
CANADA.
GOOD EVENING.
SPEAK UP TONIGHT CANADIAN
OFFICIALS ARE CALLING IT A MAJOR
AND COMPLEX INVESTIGATION AFTER
A WHITE RENTAL VAN MOWED DOWN
PEDESTRIANS DURING THE LUNCH
HOUR, LEAVING AT LEAST NINE DEAD
AND ANOTHER 16 INJURED.
MANY AT A LEVEL 1 TRAUMA CENTER.
>> TORONTO POLICE HAVE MOBILIZED
ALL AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
I CAN ASSURE THE PUBLIC ALL
AVAILABLE RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT IN TO ADDRESS THE TRAGIC
SITUATION AND INVESTIGATE THE
SITUATION.
>> AT APPROXIMATELY 1:30
EASTERN, THE CALLS STARTED
COMING IN THAT A MAN GOING ABOUT
40 MILES AN HOUR'S JUMP THE
CURB, RAMMING PEDESTRIANS AND
ANYTHING ELSE IN THE WAY.
PASSERSBY STOPPED DOING CPR ON
VICTIMS.
WITNESSES DESCRIBED THE INCIDENT
AS DELIBERATE.
A MAJOR ARTERY THROUGH TORONTO.
AFTER THE VAN STOPPED NEAR
ANOTHER MAJOR INTERSECTION, THE
SUSPECT GOT OUT OF VEHICLE.
WITNESSES REPORTED THE SUSPECT
CLAIMED TO HAVE A WEAPON BEFORE
THE POLICE TAKEDOWN.
CANADIAN AUTHORITIES HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED THE SUSPECT, WHETHER
HE ACTED ALONE, WAS PART OF
LARGER GROUP, NO WORD ON THE
MOTIVE.
THE TERROR GROUP ISIS HAS CALLED
ON ITS FOLLOWERS USE VEHICLES AS
WEAPONS AND THEY DID SO WITH
DEADLY EFFECT IN NICE, FRANCE.
IF CONFIRMED AS TERRORISM, THE
TORONTO ATTACK WOULD BE ONE OF
THE WORST ON NORTH AMERICAN SOIL
THE WORST ON NORTH AMERICAN SOI
SOIL.
>> IT'S A NIGHTMARE.
I SEEN A LADY WITH HER LEG.
OH, MAN, IT'S GRUESOME.
IT'S REALLY BAD OUT THERE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT I SEEN.
OH, MAN.
ALL THESE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
GETTING HIT ONE BY ONE.
>> TORONTO LAW ENFORCEMENT
WORKING CLOSELY WITH CANADIAN
FEDERAL OFFICIALS, CANADA'S
MINISTER FOR PUBLIC SAFETY, THE
EQUIVALENT OF THE HOMELAND
SCAREDY SECRETARY, SAID THERE IS
NO LINK BETWEEN THE INCIDENT AND